JD: Hello?
Paul: Hello, good morning!
JD: Hey, good morning.
Paul: Huge, and click.
Paul: Can you hear me?
JD: Yes, yeah, I can. Alu, Aliyah?
Paul: Olia, yes, hi, hi, how are you? Paul, my husband. He's also AI content creator and deals with our clients as well, so I would like him to…
Paul: to join the conversation, maybe take over at some… at some point, depending how long we will have the conversation. How are you?
JD: Sure, yeah, yeah.
Paul: How are you?
JD: I'm very good, nice to meet you. I'm JD, and yeah, it's good to talk with both of you.
Paul: Sure.
Paul: So, I'm curious exactly what I'm, you guys are… so there's… you represent…
Paul: I mean, what's your role? Because we're AI creators, Susan, so where do you fit into this puzzle?
JD: Yeah, so, I'll give you a little bit of background. Number one, I'm currently in Taiwan, Taipei, so I'm in Asia time zone, and being here,
JD: I have… my background is in film production, and some licensing, and as you know, with, the world of AI, my brain started going towards, like, what are some problems, what are some possibilities? And so, the last four or five months, I have…
JD: created this site called Super Immersive 8. I don't know if you've had a chance to look at it, but basically, what I believe is going to be an issue, or a need, is just like
JD: normal, ads or movies need to get rights clearance.
JD: Right? So, like, if you made a commercial today, you would need rights clearance for your commercial… for your client's legal teams, they'll ask for it. If you made movies, the same thing. You have to clear your rights.
Paul: Yeah.
JD: AI, created… Commercials, videos, films…
JD: will have the same requirement. The tricky thing is, right now.
JD: you know, different regions, different countries are writing their different AI regulation laws, right? So, EU has a law coming in August. Well, it's already being… it's already in process, but it's.
Paul: Yeah, yeah.
JD: Right? Asia has laws, Korea, US. So, on… on that…
JD: On that, what I think would be valuable for AI creators is
JD: Having, basically, a software where you can input…
JD: what platform you use? Do you have likenesses? You can put attachments in, you can do all of these things.
JD: And when you do that, you'll get back a,
JD: In the US, we would call it, like, a Carfax. I think in UK, it's, like, a HPI, you know, like, when you buy a used car, you basically… you get a report of, like, all of the, past, things with the car.
JD: With us, it's the same thing. You would get a report, you'd get a third-party validated report.
JD: of the tools, of the likenesses of the brands that you use for your AI commercial.
JD: That's where we fit in.
Paul: So you're selling a product to AI creators that they can have
Paul: If they… if there's a question about how legitimate these…
Paul: you know, the images are… if there's a kind of gray area of the legality of it all, then, I can produce this document, and that would,
Paul: And that was… Solve the problem.
JD: Yeah, we validate it. So, two things, right? The goal is for AI creators, right? When you create a commercial, going forward, when you create a commercial.
JD: your client's legal team is gonna say, what platform did you use? You know, they're gonna have some questions. And you can, at that time, try and
JD: Put together an email with attachments.
Paul: Screaming.
JD: You know, or you basically just do it with our platform, right? So, we have a platform, and you upload… you upload your PDFs, your receipts, you fill out some information.
JD: And then what you'll get back is a… kind of like a DocuSign, or you think about, like, Getty Image. It's rights cleared, right? And you get a.
Paul: document that…
JD: just hand to the legal department and say, this is all of my chain of title, here's everything that I've got.
JD: We have… and we have two versions. We have a, we have a low-end, lower-end, like, creator version for 30 bucks.
JD: Okay, so it's basically a document trail.
JD: And then we have a higher end, where we've… we will watch the commercial, we'll watch the video, and we'll flag anything that we think may actually get
JD: Flagged by a legal team, because we're keeping up with all the legal rules and the laws.
JD: And then that, that higher end is, 500, 500 bucks.
JD: But that's the idea.
Paul: At what point… I'm sorry, at what point, and who it is that's going to approach you? Is it the AI creator himself, or herself, or the client? And what makes
Paul: the… the copyright, let's say, the video legitimate, and be able… the client is able to use this video, for themselves, because
Paul: It's created with their product, or because it's their idea, or how do they claim the right of the content?
JD: Well, that's a good question, and I've been asking, you know, a lot of clients and creators, you know, what kind of happens in the process, because again, I think this is a little bit, new. So…
JD: For the most part, clients, and you tell me if this is right or wrong.
JD: when clients hire, for example, yourself, or a creator or an agency to do an AI production.
JD: They would… they would require, or they're assuming that you are going to be able to
JD: you know, not infringe. Like, not copy anything. Like, they're assuming that your final production, your final video.
JD: we'll have… rights clearance, right? Rights cleared.
Paul: Yeah, it's just an assumption, exactly, yeah.
JD: Right now, it's a… right now, honestly, in AI, it's, like, kind of like a…
JD: loose, like, yeah, we know, we know you're using AI, and we know that you're good, you know? Like, we know that you're good. But I believe in the future.
JD: clients.
JD: they're… they're going to be a little bit more… they're gonna need more. They're gonna want more, because they have to protect against lawsuits.
JD: So they're gonna say, we need to see a record, like, we need you to have rights clearance, like, whether an email, or a Word doc, or a PDF, like, show us what you did to create this video. And then that way that they feel okay, that they can, you know, use the commercial.
JD: And so that's where we come in, is we make that process faster, or easier for you.
JD: You know? Now…
JD: in the… the… when I talk to creators, some people are like, yeah, this is coming.
JD: And some people were like, I kind of do it right now. I just have a Word document, or I have a folder on my desktop, and, you know, my receipts go in there, you know, if I have an image likeness, contracts, I go… it goes in there, and they're like, I have it all, I have it on my desktop.
JD: And some people are like, I should do it, I don't do it yet.
JD: Right? And so they're kind of like, blah, blah, blah. Now…
JD: The, beauty of what we do is that
JD: We are a third party.
JD: Right? We're not the creator.
Paul: We're not…
JD: So we're like a auditor, you know, we're a third party that says, yes, this is a receipt, yes, this is a likeness contract. No, you are missing this. You know, we'll flag, hey, these are 3 things that in the EU law, says you probably should need, but you don't have right now. So we'll say.
JD: We would suggest that you go get these 3 things.
JD: And that's the role that we play.
Paul: Exactly, but… so, I'm still confused, so this… you will… you were… you're trying to sell us a product, basically. You want us to sign up and pay money.
Paul: So we can have a document to show future clients that this is the… this was the route we took in creating this, image, and it's going to cost us X amount of money, just to show a document if
Paul: They want it, and if we even need to show it, and even if it's even…
Paul: legitimate in the document that you give us, because it could be…
Paul: anybody can sign a bit of paper and say this is the path. I'm not sure that…
Paul: How legal it is anyway, to say that…
Paul: if, you know, if… if it was totally automated AI, that's when it gets flagged as potential,
Paul: You know, if you don't state something, it's,
Paul: AI, because it's automated, that's when it starts causing problems, but if it's…
Paul: that human created. You know, if it's like that, myself, I'm…
Paul: generating images by putting in key prompts. That takes away
Paul: What's JD saying is that if the image was… like, for example, someone is taking… using an avatar that looks like me.
Paul: you know, so where do I… oh, right, but where do I go and complain, in effect, right? Like, if someone is using…
Paul: Let's say… let's say that this… this been…
Paul: This document was not collected. The… the… does… is this document, by the way, has some kind of legal value, the one that you are…
Paul: Signing off?
JD: We are not an insurance company, so we would not protect…
JD: the person, you know, we would not protect you, we're not an insurance company, right? We're a tool for legal teams to use. So, for example, Paul, you mentioned… you said a couple things, and if I may.
JD: Some of it is true, and some of it, honestly, is not true.
JD: So, for example, okay, for example, showing chain of title.
JD: So, one thing that legal departments at… for maybe larger clients or whoever.
JD: In order for them to use anything created with AI, the creator needs to show that they
JD: paid for the AI platform that they used.
JD: Right? So they can't use a, they can't use a bootlegged version of Clean.
JD: Right? So, that's one thing. So, it's a receipt. It's an actual receipt that, you… you paid for this platform to use for AI.
JD: So, like, that's an example of something that, if your client
JD: Wanted legal, you know, like, they wanted to be sure that they were legally protected.
JD: From any, you know, from a lawsuit, they would have to show that the creator of the video had enough receipts of the platforms that they used.
JD: So that's one thing that we would help aggregate. Now, we're not… we're not going to make the receipt.
JD: You would upload the receipt.
JD: Right? And then we would have it in a nice document. And then you… and then this document would show that, yes, I paid for the platform, etc.
JD: there's some, there's some more detailed things. For example, prompting. Okay, so prompting is one that
JD: I think, is tough. Like, different regions will have their different, different regions will have their different rules, but for example.
JD: Okay? If you were going to make an AI video today.
JD: And you said, and in your prompt, you wrote.
JD: The lead character, is a young, teenage couple set in a world that resembles Harry Potter.
JD: Okay? You're starting to get into some fine language there, because you're naming Harry Potter in your prompt.
JD: And so, a large brand, they may go, I want to actually see all of your prompts.
JD: Because… Again, depending on the region, depending on where.
JD: That would be liable for a lawsuit.
JD: Okay, now that's a very extreme version. I gave you the easy one, which is, you absolutely do need to show receipts.
JD: You know, that you used, that you purchased, an AI platform, and not used a bootleg version or something.
JD: So those are examples of… you know, we don't,
JD: We're… again, we're not an insurance company. We're… we're a… I think it's HPI Check.
JD: Right? In the UK.
JD: So, like, if you bought a used car, there's a website that'll show you, and all they're doing is they're…
JD: They're looking at publicly available, you know, car accident data, and they're just showing, hey, this car.
JD: What had this accident, or didn't have this accident?
JD: Right? We're that. We're just showing… we're helping you Compile everything easily.
Paul: So, you're saying, mainly, it sounds like, that this, this, app or the website is going to be more for creators rather than the clients?
JD: Yeah, I think so, because right now, clients are, clients are basically assuming that creators are going to produce
JD: Legally.
Paul: do it all.
JD: They're gonna produce…
JD: you know, work that don't infringe on content. I believe from what the people that I talk to, the legal teams at the brands, you know, like, the large brands, they'll have their own legal team, and they'll probably scrub it themselves, you know, just to make sure.
Paul: Yeah. But…
JD: But from everybody that I talk to, I think this is getting pushed to the craters.
Paul: So that's… that's, also extra…
Paul: Work, extra worries, extra expenses on top of creators, unfortunately.
JD: It is, it absolutely is. I mean, and… but it's… it's not…
JD: it's not unsimilar to, like, human-made productions. You know, like, if you did a commercial today that had no AI, you still can't use copyrighted music.
JD: You know, you still can't have…
Paul: How are you?
JD: You can't have a copy… you can't have likeness of somebody, you know, you can't say that on Roberts or whatever. Like, you have to… you still have to clear all of it, you know?
JD: Just in the world of… it's a different type of clearing.
Paul: Yeah, so then for the future… for the future references, once all the laws are established and the clients are really…
Paul: Pushing onto, you know,
Paul: All the licensing, and make sure that
Paul: the stuff that we're doing is legit and legal, then we can come back to you, Ian.
JD: Yeah, that's the idea. And by the way, you know, I'm just starting out, and so I would welcome any feedback or product feedback. I don't need to… let me put it this way. I'm very happy to give you free coupon codes to try it. So, for you to try it.
Paul: Thank you.
JD: All you do is create an account, I'll give you a coupon code, and then it's as simple as logging in.
JD: Let's see, it's as simple as logging in…
JD: And then, in the platform, you… Oh, this is the…
JD: This is the admin. Oh, no, actually, here. So, in the platform, you choose which one you want, right? Again, the creator one is the…
JD: is the lesser lightweight one. The certified one is where we actually have a human watch your video, okay? But you just do this.
JD: You click continue, you write your film title, runtime, genre, and then it has a bunch of questions that we know that,
JD: That we think are just questions that you need for a verification.
JD: Tool disclosure, this is what I was saying before, like, what platform did you use, and then what model, what plan type, and then upload a receipt.
JD: And so, again, we just organize it for you, and then you'll have a PDF at the end of this, and if you need to show your client… if your client says.
JD: Did, you know, have you guys done any… or if your client says anything, like, do you, do you, have you, done any chain of title, provenance? You just give them this PDF.
Paul: Okay, thank you, that's a…
Paul: useful tool, but I think it's more, like, for the future, when the trouble starts to happen, you know, with all the rights, yeah. Because now it's a bit of a jungle with AI. It's all over the place.
Paul: People are copying everything, copying each other, but it needs to get more regulated, yeah.
JD: August is when the EU law kicks in, and, you know, the EU law is very comprehensive about all things AI, but one thing that it does say is that if you create AI videos, that you have to document, and again, like.
JD: Some of this will get worked out, you know, but you have to document how you did it.
JD: You know.
Paul: Sleep.
JD: And so, it just depends. You're absolutely right, like, it's kind of like the jungle right now.
JD: And, my…
JD: my view on the future is that brands will be more conservative. Like, right now, they're probably a little bit more, like.
JD: Close one eye, open the other.
Paul: Yeah, working loosely, yeah.
JD: In the future, they'll be a little bit more conservative, because their corporate lawyers will say, no, no, no, no, we need some clearance here, so just make sure the production company or the agency, you know, make sure that they have all their files, you know, things like that, so…
JD: Have you, have you been asked, at all for…
JD: legal, or any sort of receipts, or any sort of,
Paul: No. Never so far, no.
Paul: It's been just, kind of, a privacy agreement.
Paul: No disclosure agreements.
Paul: You know, like, just a verbal kind of, please, just don't post a video, this is our product.
Paul: Could you please not post this video onto your social media, things like that?
Paul: And some would literally ask me to sign the disclosure of, like, privacy.
Paul: that's it so far. Like, even it was, quite expensive products.
Paul: But… I don't know, I find, yeah, it's just… it's still all over the place.
JD: Yeah, so maybe… maybe you don't need it, well, maybe you don't need us right now, so, you know, and that may be…
Paul: I think it's a matter of time, JD. I think that you are playing ahead.
Paul: Which is a good thing, maybe just a longer time, right? To reap the fruits of what you've done, but I think that this is the future, you know, give it another…
Paul: Maybe a few months, maybe 6 months, and it's getting, it's getting, quite chaotic, so…
Paul: I think it's just a matter of time.
JD: Yeah, I think so, too. I think for me right now,
JD: you know, it's really me and another person. For me right now.
JD: I… you know, I feel like… I feel like this will be needed. Like, I just… I've been in this business for a while. I just feel like there's no way legal teams are gonna be okay with this exposure. Oh, by the way, the other thing that I haven't talked about is, like, different platforms.
JD: Right?
JD: some you can't even use, because they don't own their own image libraries. Now, so a lot of the Chinese ones.
JD: No, no, no large… okay with that. No way.
Paul: Are you talking about stock images?
JD: Yeah, like, I don't know if you know the platform Seed Dance. I don't know if you remember that, there was a video of, Tom, Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt fighting on the,
JD: ceiling.
Paul: Yeah, yeah. Yeah, so…
JD: There's no way, there's no way, there's no way that anyone, any brand, would be able to use that, because Seed Dance doesn't own Tom Cruise's stock image, or, you know, image, or Brad Pitt. Like, they don't own it.
JD: So, there's no way.
Paul: Yeah, yeah.
JD: It's a seed dance and say, even if you are gonna make a really good prompt, Because it's just…
JD: It's just too easy for Disney to sue.
JD: No, I, Marvel. I'm sorry, I don't exactly know who would own Tom Cruise and Brad Pitt's likeness in that case, but whoever does would just sue the AI platform.
JD: Easy. That's an easy lawsuit.
JD: You know? And so, this is…
JD: I, I, I think this is coming. My question…
JD: It's really more like, are the questions that my survey is asking, are those the right questions?
JD: And that probably is more for, like, creators, like, if you are being asked to provide this, this, this, this, this.
JD: What I want to do is just make it easy for you to, make it easier for you to provide it.
JD: So my question is, like, am I asking… is my survey asking the right question? Is it runtime? Is it likeness? Is it whatever? You know? And so that's why I want to get more, creators or agencies to use it, and just give me feedback. And maybe they'll say, oh, you know, I was asked for this info, and it's not one of your questions.
JD: Okay, well, I'll add it, I'll add it to my survey.
Paul: great.
Paul: Something with my connection, or with your connection.
JD: Can you hear me? Can you still hear me?
JD: Hello, hello?
Paul: Yeah, yeah, I can have you, man.
Paul: Hmm, are we connected?
Paul: Let's not down here.
Paul: Apology, just a second.
JD: Yep.
Paul: Okay, well, good to know the setup, JD.
Paul: I'm not sure if this… Israeli for us at this moment in time.
Paul: But, you know, we're just not getting asked these questions by anybody, and
Paul: we'll be that… we're not creating images that I think has any,
Paul: Yeah, I'm not trying to do lightnesses or…
Paul: Or themes based on, on, on… you know.
Paul: people or products that are liable. I mean, you're not… It's… it's more just…
Paul: We're just creating from scratch, you know, it's all our own, promise. I'm not referencing anything, but…
Paul: like I said, things change, and this is a…
Paul: This is what we're saying, things do change and things evolve. So maybe another day when you…
JD: Yeah, do you… do you do more, images or videos? Or, like, what's the ratio? Images.
Paul: Images, and there's so many images, it's just…
JD: Okay.
Paul: Somebody might want to, series of images to promote their products.
JD: Yeah, yeah.
Paul: So, it's all tied into them, not to, you know, not drawing from another source. Yes, mainly, mainly we work with, clients' products, fashion.
JD: Oh, okay.
Paul: e-commerce, listings, and and they have their own product, and logically, I am…
Paul: using always, like, I create the background, or I get an inspiration of the background, let's say, or it's a plane background, or it's just a yacht, or it's a hotel. I mean, it's just, like, no specific names. No, it's just common…
Paul: common sense to me, you know, that how can I use
Paul: This, that, Tonya, or the other, you know, name.
Paul: Yeah, so far, so far, like.
JD: Yeah, I think images are…
JD: probably a lot safer to do, you know? Really, you know, my platform is probably more so for videos, because videos,
JD: I think people… I think… I think people are just a little bit more weary when it comes to AI video than AI image. Wait, can I ask what, platform… like, do you use Nano Banana, or do you… what… what kind of AI software do you typically use?
Paul: Not a banana, not a banana, but we have access to…
Paul: Several, flippy, wavy… Clean, it's just, I guess, every… More of a, like, general product. It depends on the products that you're trying to create. I mean, it's a certain,
Paul: Oh, man.
Paul: tools required different, you know… obviously, the free… the ones that are unlimited and not as expensive, you know, like the Nana Bananas.
Paul: But it depends how sophisticated you want your…
Paul: images of the curse to date, and you sort of… It's my version.
JD: Yep.
JD: Yeah, well, you know, in any case, it's very nice meeting you. You know, like, definitely, I just followed you on Instagram, so hopefully we keep connected, and, you know,
JD: I guess, again, from my end, I'm looking for more creators that just basically try my platform. I'm really just looking for people to go through with it, use it, and then tell me…
JD: what other questions they're being asked. And right now, if people are not asking you for questions, then there's probably not a good fit to use the platform right now, so…
Paul: Yeah, I think, yeah, I probably would be if the client's is of that.
Paul: Level, that, you know, that would have a kind of legal force behind them, but…
Paul: If you're dealing one-on-one with the customer.
Paul: a business that are quite happy just to… Have the images produced.
Paul: There seems to be no legal team behind it.
Paul: Yep. Yeah.
Paul: It's quite easy, for now, it's quite straightforward.
Paul: But all the best. It's definitely, like I said, a matter of time for you.
Paul: just, there will be more issues coming up soon. This is when it's time for you to step in.
JD: Yeah, yeah, we'll see, we'll see.
JD: Well, we'll see. We'll, you know, keep tracking the news and everything, so we'll see.
Paul: What is your background, if I may ask?
JD: I was a… I'm a film producer. My training is really a unit production manager. We call it a line producer on movie sets, so I manage the crew, I manage the line… the line item budget, you know, that kind of thing. Now, I do…
JD: not just movies, I do, licensing, like, international licensing, so I have clients in,
JD: well, AI hardware, VR, you know, so… kind of do, like, business-to-business, business development.
JD: Yeah, but focused on licensing, okay? That's kind of my area of focus.
Paul: Mr.
JD: bring my past in film and licensing together, that's where I go, wait a second, you know, this AI stuff, yeah, some people are gonna…
JD: People are gonna need some sort of, like, rights clearance, so… That's why I built.
Paul: Sure, sure, yeah.
Paul: Okay. Thank you, thank you so much. Yeah, thanks.
JD: If you…
Paul: Is it?
JD: Yeah, thank you for your time. If you know anybody that's doing AI videos, please pass them along. And again, I have free coupon codes, I'm really just looking to meet more creators, so if you know anybody that…
Paul: Could you send your website, please? .
JD: Your website…
Paul: link, or we have it in the… I have it on the email.
JD: Yeah, yeah, yeah, I sent to you from the email, yeah, so it's super immersive 8.
JD: Yep.
Paul: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Paul: Okay.
JD: Thank you. Thank you so much.
Paul: Nice to meet you.
JD: Paul, nice to meet you.
Paul: All the best. Ciao. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.